by the way you know you know what's the
one state that has
the lowest crime in all of America that
a lot of people are moving to right now
and no one's talking about it you know
what state it is I'll guess Idaho okay
do you know Idaho is one of the states
at the top
with the most people who have a license
to carry it's eight percent okay license
to carry you go to a restaurant there's
10 people there if one of them is
carrying yeah okay it's good so guess
what happens you want to go rob a place
go rob a place so now to the people that
are saying if we bang guns that's the
solution no problem there's something
called Data Chicago leads the way okay
Baltimore leads the way you can go to a
lot of these states and cities with
strong gun laws and see how it's working
out it's called case study
thank you